dans le conflit des infirmières ça
n'avance pas cinq fédérations des
personnels hospitaliers appellent à la
grève avec manifestation nationale à
paris jeudi prochain les négociations
avec claude evin ont abouti dans un
premier temps un déblocage de 1 milliard
de francs c'est à peine un pourboire et
ponts des syndicats négociations
suspendues hier soir reprendront cet
après-midi et la coordination
infirmières dans tout ça me direz vous
et bien elle est issue de la base et
réclament le droit à la parole dans la
négociation parce que dit cette
coordination les syndicats ne
représentent que 5 % de notre profession
l'enquète de françoise joly
toute la matinée les infirmières
grévistes cet hôpital
15e arrondissement de paris ont
recueilli des signatures en soutien à
leur grève à leurs revendications
et depuis le début de ce conflit si la
revalorisation de leurs salaires est au
centre de leurs luttes ces infirmières
se bat aussi pour que soient reconnus
leur coordination
ce mouvement spontané à l'origine de la
grève le fait de créer un mouvement
coordination ça nous permettait que nous
infirmière sans idées politiques
derrière on ça nous permettait de nous
battre tout seul
les infirmières sont très peu syndiqués
on n'est pas très au courant de ce
qu'ils de ce qui nous divise et on veut
pas du tout politique
et pourtant hier soir au ministère de la
santé ce sont les syndicats qui se sont
assis autour de la table des
négociations
la coordination elle était reçue à part
par le ministre claude evin le ministère
a fait un premier pas en débloquant une
enveloppe de 1 milliard de francs pour
les infirmières
selon la cfdt cela reviendrait à
accorder un peu plus de 300 francs par
mois à chacune d'entre elles des
propositions qui ne font pas la sphère
des syndicats
reposé moins de 300 points affirmé hier
qu'ils en demandent 2000 qui ne sont que
la revalorisation de refaire de pouvoir
d'achat depuis dix ans c'est
complètement inacceptable
à 14 ans les négociations entre les
syndicats et le ministre de la santé
devrait reprendre et pour concilier
d'une part la politique de rigueur du
gouvernement et d'autre part les
revendications des blouses blanches
il faudra à semble-t-il un certain temps